mais quelle aventure bonjour bonjour
alors à tout le monde et rfi damart
particulier à à nos concitoyennes fort
de france alors miguel laventure vous
avez 72 ans vous êtes conseiller
municipal de l'opposition vous êtes
également conseiller exécutif de la
septième en charge notamment des
finances et des fonds européens
vous avez été pour la première fois
candidat aux municipales en 2001 qu'est
ce qui vous motive toujours aujourd'hui
à bien écouter ce qui me motivait et
autres types accentué aujourd'hui par la
situation de radio de désastre que tout
le monde connaît de la gestion de fort
de france qui est une ville capitale
mais qui aujourd'hui à une pratique qui
désespère et par conséquent très
clairement aujourd'hui il faut donner à
cette jetée royaux de la martinique
fort-de-france l'opportunité d'être
l'élément de fierté que chaque
martiniquais des chaque martiniquais
puisse revendiquer et faire en sorte que
les gens ne quittent pas la ville vous
savez que la population a diminué à
fort-de-france beaucoup plus que dans la
moyenne de la martinique mais qu'au
contraire ce soir un élément de
motivation un élément d'attractivité et
surtout un moteur pour fort-de-france
mais pour l'ensemble de la martinique
candidats de haut municipal depuis 2001
est ce que ce n'est pas une candidature
de trous profonds miguel laventure je ne
sais pas si elle est de trop mais ce que
je sais c'est qu'elle est indispensable
c'est parce que aujourd'hui je constate
que quand on regarde l'offre politique
qui est faite et bien vous voyez qu'il y
a le sortant qui est on va dire dans une
continuité de 74 ans alors je ne sais
pas si l' on peut considérer que c'est
de trop ou de suffisant ou qu'il faut
encore et puis vous avez des
candidatures qui sont d'expiration avec
une finalité politique qui est
absolument pas la mienne c'est à dire
qui de ces script à dans la république
et par conséquent je pense
qu'aujourd'hui
compte tenu de la situation très
franchement très franchement la seule
façon pour la martinique de s'en sortir
avec fort de france qui puisse donner un
coup de rein qui puisse retrouver un
dynamisme qui puisse roi donne
une espérance c'est de s'appuyer sur
toutes les opportunités qui peuvent
exister en particulier le fait que nous
soyons dans un contexte qu'est la france
avec je dirais la nécessité d'aller
arracher ce qui ne vient pas tout de
suite et ce qui ne vient pas
naturellement mais aussi de le faire au
niveau de l'europe
et puis d'aller le faire au niveau
international et par conséquent très
clairement aujourd'hui il faut quelqu'un
une d'equipe des compétences qui est
l'envi mais aussi la compétence et
surtout le contact la relation pour
aller obtenir je répète à la force de la
volonté les moyens indispensables ou les
foyalais de l'effroyable une reste deux
minutes quand on dit qu'on ne vous
n'arrivez pas fier votre liste que vous
n'arrivez pas à trouver les 53
nécessaire pour faire la liste
je ne sais pas qui vous a dit ça parce
que manifestement vous n'êtes pas
informés bon vous ne venez pas nous voir
par conséquent je ne sais pas si c'est
un rêve que vous avez une révélation
mais il ya la question de la semaine
prochaine et puis vous aurez non alors
vous l'avez dit on dit que par
conséquent le colporteur des
informations erronées
évidemment ça nous retombe bien je vous
pose directement la question alors on
est au centre du débat de ces
municipales la situation financière de
fort de france une véritable catastrophe
selon vous bah écoutez vous connaissez
les chiffres vous connaissez à
l'actualité
le dernier élément c'était il ya
exactement une semaine la chambre
régionale des comptes a dit de manière
veut dire est conclusive comme
l'aboutissement de ces investigations et
bien il y à 60 millions de déficit sur
un budget qui est je sais pas s'il faut
compter je dirais les dépenses ou les
recettes puisqu'il ya 60 millions de
déficit et bien autour de 170 millions
si on fait la moyenne entre les deux et
par conséquent vous voyez la proportion
que c'est vous voyez que ça n'est pas
concevable et que ce n'est même pas
imaginable et que dans ces conditions il
y a là une situation
je dirais qu'il devrait susciter la
mobilisation collective je note que le
sort très bien il en fait un élément
presque de triomphe en disant qu' ils
arrivent à avoir encore la main pour
pouvoir faire quelque chose
je pense qu'aujourd'hui il y à un
sursaut est indispensable à mettre en
oeuvre à fort de france il y a besoin de
toutes les compétences de toutes les
bonnes volontés il y a besoin de
rassembler il ya besoin de faire en
sorte à tous les niveaux on puisse
utiliser le meilleur de ce que font de
france pu avoir et au delà et par
conséquent oui nous aurons besoin de
nous appuyer
y compris sur la collectivité
territoriale de martinique la cdm dont
vous avez rappelé j'ai la responsabilité
en particulier des finances publiques et
par conséquent je sais ce que ça veut
dire redresser à partir d'une situation
catastrophique qui a été laissé qu'est
ce qu'il faudrait faire alors vous avez
un peu élaborée ça mais qu'est ce qu'il
faudrait faire quelles actions fortes en
20 secondes si tout le temps qu'il nous
reste
mais je vous ai dit d'abord changer le
système qui consiste à dépenser sans
savoir compter se concentre et
deuxièmement aller chercher la recette
là où elle est
clairement ça n'est pas dans la poche
des fouilles à l'aise en effet les infos
en augmentant les impôts ce serait
criminel et deuxièmement c'est en allant
là où aujourd'hui on refuse de nous
entendre mais parce que ceux qui parlent
n'arrive pas à se faire entendre
je répète au niveau où ils sont pas de
même ben non parce qu'ils sont un temps
ils sont pas l'expérience ils sont
parlantes rejoint j'ai rien en tout cas
j'ai fait le constat qu'il n'y arrive
pas et puis également au niveau de
l'europe
et j'ajoute au niveau international mais
quelle aventure je vous remercie c'est
moi qui prenais
[Musique]